[Music]  yes it's a Guitar World Championship  time again  [Music]  there are no limits for the competition  not even in taste  for the 22nd time people from all over  the world traveled to the cold and rainy  Finnish town of Oulu to join the fun but  the air guitar community is also moved  by something else make air not war  [Music]  that's why all these people do it  because it is silly but at the the  deepest level and core of air guitar are  these these feelings of love and  happiness and peace and we are doing our  part as humanitarians and peace  ambassadors by raiding this energy into  the world  the artist who managed to spread his  energy most convincingly this year was  Matthew aristotle burns of the United  States he also won the title last year s  winner he gets you won't believe it's a  guitar a real electric one  [Music]